my sexy looks
Matthew Perry recalls making out with
Valerie Bertinelli in his new Memoir
friends lovers and the big terrible
things
I guess if you put my marriage on TV it
would be a comedy and it was during her
marriage to Eddie Van Halen you're
needed for your 10 minutes of work a day
oh yes yes thank you thank you following
the massive reaction on social media
vows seemingly confirming the night in
question by way of Taylor Swift's music
it's me
I I want the problem it's me Valerie
shares a tick tock inspired by the
singer's latest hit
[Music]
and that's not all Valerie's also
responded to comments referencing the
viral story in her Emoji reaction says
it all so what happened she's very
professional well a section from
Matthew's book was previewed online and
it went there with his past crush on
Valerie cut the tape the two were
co-stars over 30 years ago on the
short-lived sitcom Sydney E.T captured
some of their flirty moments on the set
oh yeah I can see you you're doing that
sexy look okay my sexy look
when I first got this show I'd read in
TV Guide or something like that that she
was not pleasant to work with and then
we found out that that was like just
baloney it kind of distanced the first
day and she just she just said you know
where are we going to lunch and I went
oh okay the friend star says he was
quote madly in love with Valerie as
Matthew tells it one night he went over
to her and Eddie's house we did a Van
Halen joke before too and like just
inside stuff I think is funny after the
rocker quote passed out amid the
festivities Matthew writes quote Valerie
and I had a long elaborate makeout
session with Eddie just quote 10 feet
away from them so let me just tell you
something okay Matthew remembers quote I
told her I thought about doing that for
a long time and she had said it right
back to me he says Valerie never spoke
of the night again and a quote
devastated Matthew got the hint another
Revelation details about another co-star
crush this one on Jennifer Aniston
excuse me Alex seem to have dropped my
ball
yeah so Matthew says he was quote
immediately taken by her but she quote
declined after he asked her out
even though he was still attracted to
her Matthew writes that they were able
to quote sell right past the past and
focus on the fact that we had both
gotten the best job Hollywood had to
offer
foreign
[Music]
thank you